salut les mantallot aujourd'hui je
m'assieds pas ce que je vais vous
raconter une histoire
la fabuleuse histoire du baromètre de
bord est autant cette histoire est
passionnante autant j'ai des révélations
à faire sur l'histoire en elle-même à la
fin de la vidéo
un beau matin ou un bel après-midi j'en
sais rien ernest rutherford qui était
prix nobel de chimie en 1908 reçoit un
coup de fil de l'un de ses collègues
son problème qui était prof également
expliqué un gros problème avec un
étudiant sur une question de physique
en fait il a posé une question de
physique un étudiant dans un devoir
l'étudiant lui a répondu et il veut lui
mettre zéro pour sa réponse
alors que l'étudiant réclame lui qu'on
lui met un vin du coup le professeur en
question et d'étudiants se sont mis
d'accord pour faire appel à un arbitre
impartial qui pourrait déterminer qui a
raison qui a tort
la question du devoir de physique qui
pose problème était montré comment à
l'aide d'un baromètre vous pouvez
calculer la taille d'un immeuble et
l'étudiant avait répondu cette réponse
très maline on prend le baromètre on
l'attaché une corde on vous montre aux
immeubles on laisse tomber le baromètre
jusqu'en bas de l'immeuble
on marque la corde on remonte la corde
on mesure la corde au fur et à mesure qu
on la remonte et à la fin on a la taille
de l'immeuble la taille de la corde plus
la taille du baromètre donc en soit
l'étudiant en question avait raison
puisque il répondait concrètement et
pleinement à la question qui lui avait
été posée il donnait une réponse une
solution mais le problème c'est que ce
n'était pas la solution qui était
attendu on ne pouvait pas lui donner ses
examens de physique en utilisant cette
réponse là qui était plus dans la panse
de logis rutherford à ce moment-là veut
laisser une chance à l'étudiant en
question est lié à ce que vous pouvez me
trouver une solution pour calculer la
taille de l'immeuble une vraie solution
est là l'étudiant en question sort une
dizaine de solutions différentes mais
qui sont toutes du même acabit comme par
exemple on met le baromètre au dessus du
toit on le laisse tomber mon chrono mais
de son temps de chute et après on
utilise la formule il segal j'étais au
carré sur deux pour trouver la distance
donc la taille de l'immeuble il trouve
d'autres solutions comme ça avec la
position du soleil avec le poids du
baromètre avec la taille du baromètre
sur montant l'escalier à chaque fois on
met une trace sur le mur pour avoir le
nombre de fois on a dupliqué la taille
par an m faire aussi y est comme ça le
baromètre en l'immeuble est calculé en
fonction des oscillations la taille du
mieux par rapport à la longueur de la
corde et même une superbe solution qui
est d'aller dans l'immeuble au sous-sol
rencontre le gardien et lui dire vous
voyez j'ai un bon baromètre là mais je
vous le donne si vous me donnez la
taille de l'immeuble et c'est à ce
moment là que ruth et reformulé
monde si c'est la réponse qu'on attend
de lui qu'elle est la bonne réponse
entre guillemets en tout cas la réponse
attendue à cette question est là l'élève
en question répond oui mais oui je sais
exactement ce que vous voulez par
rapport à la pression du baromètre et je
connais la formule évidemment mais j'en
ai juste marre qu'on m'explique comment
je dois penser puisque évidemment la
réponse était de calculer la pression
atmosphérique au bas de l'immeuble
celle en haut de l'immeuble et d'en
déduire du coup la taille de l'immeuble
par rapport à la différence de pression
atmosphérique cette histoire est
vraiment drôle et passionnante parce
qu'elle met en scène deux personnes
l'étudiant en question est censé être
bornes il bord qui a reçu le prix nobel
de physique en 1922 et dont l arbitre en
question celui qui raconte en fait cette
histoire comme je voulais 17 héritèrent
forme je trouve qu'elle fait partie de
ces histoires qui nous ouvre aussi
l'esprit pour se dire ok c'est pas parce
qu'on attend ce chemin là deux mois que
je dois le l'emprunter toutes les
solutions aussi peuvent être
potentiellement bonne et peuvent mettre
personnel en clair il n'y a pas qu'une
seule façon de penser pour résoudre des
problèmes
un petit peu comme la vidéo sur la
créativité que je vous ai faite hier
mais j'ai fait quelques recherches pour
avoir les sources quand même de tout cet
événement et il s'avère que c'est une
légende urbaine
ça n'a pas eu lieu en tout cas pas
rentrer rutherford et bord parce que la
première fois que rupert fort des porcs
se sont rencontrés c'est en 1912 et en
1912 bord n'était déjà plus étudiant
depuis quelques années et s'étaient
rencontrés pour travailler justement sur
des projets scientifiques donc ça ne
pouvait pas être une histoire vraie
quand on creuse et qu'on cherche encore
plus on se rend compte malheureusement
que c'est une histoire fictive
elle a été écrite dans un journal dont
je vous mets le nom juste ici en 1958
est offert à mesure on lui a attribué
deux noms à savoir le nom de bord pour
les étudiants et le nom de robert ford
pour l' arbitre quand j'ai eu
connaissance de cette histoire il ya
quelques années je crois que c'était une
histoire vraie parce qu'on me l'avait
racontée comme étant une histoire vraie
et je la trouvais assez intéressante en
soi et après en cherchant j'ai eu une
légère déception et cette déception a
été gommée parce que peu importe que ce
soit pas attribué réellement à bord
auteur ford peu importe que ce soit pas
arrivé je trouve que le message que
donne l'histoire est plus important que
le fait qu'elle était réelle ou non
ainsi s'achève cette vidéo hors sujet
hors sujet mais pas que de la playlist
hors sujet mais pas que j'espère que ça
vous aura intéressé et peut-être vous
aurez découvert cette histoire comme ça
demain ce sera aussi une vidéo un petit
peu différente je referai un blog demain
ça fait très longtemps que j'avais pas
fais là j'étais au festival fasse ici il
ya une petite semaine de ça j'ai fait
plein d'image donc je vous mets un blog
avant de choisir un bloc par semaine
maintenant j'en fais un petit peu moins
de temps en temps je sais que c'est pas
forcément ce qui est le plus regardé sur
chen mais ça me tient à coeur de
continuer à faire ça s'appelle quand
même le mental blog tout ça si cette
histoire et cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir et rendez vous
demain à 17h chao je joue mon spectacle
en entier le 23 septembre à la garenne
colombes c'est la date la plus proche de
paris si jamais vous voulez venir sinon
il ya toutes les dates de tournée sur
mon site